in times of crisis we look to our
leaders for inspiration of course
retired four-star general Stanley
McChrystal is very familiar with the
stresses of leadership during turbulent
times he commanded u.s. and
international forces in Afghanistan and
he led Joint Special Operations Command
the nation's premier military
counterterrorism force in 2015 he also
co-wrote team of teams a book about
leadership he applied the lessons he
learned fighting abroad to businesses
nonprofits and other organizations and
General Stanley McChrystal joins us now
from outside Washington DC general good
morning thank you very much for being
here you know President Trump right now
is doing a very difficult thing he's
trying to balance a hopeful message for
the country we will get through this
with the cold hard realities that many
of his medical advisers are giving him
which is this is going to get worse what
advice would you have for him as he
tries to navigate those two polls and
faces criticism that he's being way more
hopeful than truthful yeah I think you
could take some lessons from history if
we went to the beginning of the Civil
War with Abraham Lincoln or the
beginning of the New Deal with Franklin
Delano Roosevelt or December 8 1941 what
those leaders did was they outlined a
difficult problem ahead they exhibited
confidence that we would come through in
the end but they didn't try to minimize
it they said it was going to be
difficult we were going to demand a lot
of the American people and of course a
lot of our leaders and then they
proceeded to live up to that and that's
what I think is needed right now yeah
why does candor so important well
because you can lie to anybody for a
little while and they don't after a
while everybody figures it out and your
credibility goes down particularly if I
think in combat soldiers see what's
happening on the ground so trying to
tell them it's different than it is is a
waste of time so it's respect to be
honest to people general how do you get
honest with people without spreading
panic well
be the size of this kind of problem
particularly the different nature at the
idea of pandemic is a little bit
frightening so I think the first thing
you do is you say this is a big problem
but we are a big country we are a big
world we can do this together I think
what you say is we are going to bring
every resource every leader the
capability of every part of our nation
in the world against this problem there
will be a little bit of panic on the
part of people but at the end of the day
if you don't exhibit this kind of focus
this kind of absolute commitment they
will fill their minds with all the
things that frighten them I think you're
so right about that it reminds me of
that famous line in the movie you can't
handle the truth
we could handle the truth we and then we
know exactly what we're dealing with I
think that that's very important so you
make a good point but I love the tease
that Tony said going to you that you
compare the government's response this
crisis reminds you to the early months
of fighting al Qaeda what you mean by
that well this challenge to this when we
started fighting al Qaeda in Iraq they
were a different kind of enemy they were
this vastly dispersed Network
organization that didn't follow
traditional hierarchy although most
terrorist groups before that had what we
found is we were purpose-built to go
after the traditional kind of terrorist
groups so we had to do was
geographically dispersed ourselves over
76 different bases we had to synchronize
ourselves every day so we became a
virtual command not because it was a
great idea that one of us had but
because we had to do that that's
essentially what's happening right now
the corona virus is a difficult economic
problem that's a difficult health
problem but it's creating a special
dynamic and that
is the requirement to stay separated
it's so businesses government have all
got to operate with people working from
home in a new environment we can do this
we know how to do this but we've gotta
focus well general you bring up an
interesting point which is the question
of trade-offs we are we are effectively
sacrificing our economy and everybody in
that economy for the sake of public
health that's a complicated equation as
somebody who I'm sure is had to make
calculations regarding people's lives
and safety how do you balance one
economic health which can become public
health against lives and an illness yeah
particularly true of this pandemic in my
view requires it's the fire that's in
front of us right now and we have to get
that under control or it will burn for a
tremendous amount of time so I think
that there's going to be short-term
economic pain and it's going to be
significant I think everybody knows that
by now but if we don't do the kinds of
actions that require government
intervention stay at home social
distancing then this thing could get
much worse than it would be and of
course could last much much longer than
it should generally we know you're
currently advising a local hospital
we've been talking all morning about the
desperate need for supplies and
resources that hospitals are
experiencing what is that hospital
telling you what are you telling them in
a situation like this
well it's interesting it's a big
hospital system and what's going to
happen is they are going to be
overwhelmed like all hospital systems
and I think what's gonna happen is many
of the workers are going to start to
feel abandoned they're going to be out
there working tremendous number of hours
they're going to be at risk they're
going to be simultaneously worried about
their families they will probably be
under resourced in things they need and
there's a great potential for them to
feel as though they're guilty that they
can't take care of people as well as
they think that they should but also
that they're not being supported we can
go on TV and see how much we care for
healthcare providers but the reality is
they will feel like soldiers on the
front line who are not
what they need and so I think it's
important for them to create communities
of connection the leadership of the
hospital system who's a very strongly or
a doctor you know
forgive me but you've got to have a
constant concern we got a general week I
apologize we have to go